hey guys Joey here back with another
unboxing this time for the Nier automata
black box edition why it's white now
this actually belongs to Miguel
concepción whose review you can see on
GameSpot calm now if you want one of
these for yourself too bad because
they're also now on square enix's
website but you can get one on Amazon
from a third-party reseller for six
hundred and fifty dollars so let's open
up and see if it's worth any of those
prices should you go go alright alright
be gentle is the gals trying to be very
gentle since this does not belong to me
the old lacing what's your technique
with the razor blade to cut it like your
paper pen slice but okay so we got two
of these flaps actually
no no status reports one office yet what
happened there is more plastic on this
side anticipated Shh
too bad so we're gonna go this way
yeah open both flaps apparently hmm is
black
ready so inside we have steelbook cover
of Nier automata which is very
nice-looking the other side of it on the
other side is a looks like a sheikah
sling logo but it would be hey all right
we also have a very large thick
well-constructed
art book right there mmm that's right
there ah also inside
[Music]
she is
yura to be open and these are a lot
easier than the personals
[Music]
your seller sir plans
yeah Miki's he's first look I can't I
can't
[Music]
all right let's take her out yeah this
is um choking hazard okay okay fat we
got our safety warnings in Japanese
Spanish English and also German yeah I'm
gonna lick it all right take her out
here
oh yes of course you'd be taped so much
sleep raft now she looks good looks good
so in addition to all that stuff you got
there's some lot of cardboard in here
but also the limited edition black boxes
ition comes with a bunch of DLC you can
download including some skins for your
pod including one that looks like a
Playstation one oh yeah let's open this
one up so we got the physical copy of
the game and here's the deal see right
here what you can probably should show
that oh you can see all the wonderful
pod skins for your little guy right
there
cool oh and another disc comes in here
which is the original soundtrack of the
game as well got the part inside of the
cover right there so good Center so
that's all the stuff that was in the
near automata black box edition which is
now black boxing set white so we have
the game itself we have the original
soundtrack all the DLC here the figurine
and the art book beautiful lovely art
let's go through one more time okay and
that's it for this unboxing if you one
see more of them you can subscribe to
our YouTube channel I gotta put all the
stuff back so that Miguel doesn't yell
at me and you can open himself alright
you guys later
[Music]